if you're having a bad day or feel like
everything is going wrong you may be
tempted to blame it on the phenomenon
known as Mercury retrograde it's a
period that happened in Smoke multiple
times a year and we're about to enter
the final one of this year's cycle but
what does Mercury retrograde actually
mean CBS Saturday morning co-host Dana
Jacobson separates fact from fiction
for thousands of years people have
looked heavenward to the stars and the
Planets For answers to all kinds of
questions here on Earth but Ken what
happens out there say Mercury retrograde
affect our lives back here depends on
who you ask
astrologer Rebecca Gordon insists yes to
the planets have an actual impact in how
we live our daily lives they absolutely
do in what way first of all we can look
at a planet like Mercury which rules
Communications now when Mercury is
moving forward in its natural motion
Communications go generally easily
though when Mercury goes out of its
natural orbit say in retrograde there
tends to be all sorts of wires crossed
in miscommunications astrophysicist
Jackie Faraday strongly disagrees it's
millions of miles away from us so
millions of miles and a very small rock
is not going to impact you your body and
your world Mercury retrograde is a
period in which the planet appears to
move backwards in the sky and in the
definition is where we find agreement
but it's not really going backwards
Mercury is actually not moving backwards
at all
so what is going on
think of the solar system as a running
track with the sun being the infield and
the lanes the orbits of the planets
Earth has the third Lane Mercury is
closest to the Sun so it has the inside
Lane orbiting around the Sun about three
times as fast as Earth from outside the
solar system that looks like Mercury
lapping Earth on the track but from
Earth's point of view look at how
Mercury's path appears with both planets
moving perspective changes and from
Earth it looks like Mercury changes
Direction so if Mercury isn't actually
going backwards can that affect us
Earthlings
it's very natural that people feel that
their lives are in chaos during the
Mercury retrograde actually and I mean
my advice is that if you take things a
little slower
and during the retrograde things will be
a lot easier so when you ask is there
anything that could possibly be
happening with Mercury that could be
affecting you your day that your coffee
spilled that you got broken up with
absolutely not
fact is astrology has been considered a
pseudoscience for more than 200 Years
yet millions of people still believe we
want to know that we're safe and if the
world is chaotic and things happen
randomly
then it makes us very anxious but
psychoanalysts Elite Atlas author of
emotional inheritance warns not to put
too much in the hands of astrology it's
not that we can actually blame anything
on astrology it's uh at the end whatever
is our responsibility comes back to
visit us I do want people to understand
the science and then at the end of that
lesson if you still want to walk away
and make the decision about what you
think is impacting you okay but have the
science first
so what do you believe are our lives
written in science or in the stars for
CBS mornings Dina Jacobson New York
okay so if your life is chaos during
Mercury retrograde
um maybe your life is just chaos
saying I
I had a roommate in my 20s who when
things were feeling a little funky she'd
be like girl Mercury's in retrograde oh
okay I like the idea of the little bit
of the science and a little bit of the
Stars okay all right
somewhat somewhat